سيدتي الرئيسه اعضاء
المحكمه لقد اظهر المحامون بان مقدم
الدعوه قد فشل في اثبات قضيته في فرض
التدابير
المؤقرة حاولت محاوله لتضليل المحكمه ل
اظهار بان هنالك هذا النزاع قائم الامر
الثاني مقدم الدعوه قد فشل في تحقيق
الاشتراطات لحقوق ذات صله يجب حمايتها في
هذا الظروف ثالثا الواقع البسيط هو بان
الاحداث والتي هي موضوع هذه الدعوه تحدث
في اطار حرب كانت حماس وراها وراءها وايضا
بموجب اطار عمل القانون الدولي الانساني
وهي لا
تخضع بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
رابعا المعياري الضرر الذي يمكن جبره
والالحاح لم يتم ايضا اثباته هنا اسرائيل
تاخذ بشكل مستمر خطوات ثابته بالعمل مع
الاخرين من اجل التعامل مع الحاله
الانسانيه في غزه خامسا واخيرا لقد اذنا
بانه في كل التدابير المؤقته المطلوبه
هي غير متناسبه و وكل هذا يلفت الانتباه
الى مسالتين
اساسيتين تنشق من هذه الاجراءات اولا بان
مقدم الدعوه يسعى الى عرض صوره اسرائيل
كدوله خارجه عن القانون
والتي وتعتبر نفسها فوق و القانون وقدم
ويحاول ان يقدم مقدمه طلب اسرائيل بانها
دوله كل خدماتها
العامه جيشها
ومجتمعها الذين هم ملتزمين مع الاخلاق
والقانون وهم في بغرض تدمير تعداد سكاني
كامل وهذا خاطئ بالكامل يمكنني ان اشهد
على هذا وك نائب الامين العام للقانون
الدولي وفي هذا الموقع انصح الحكومه الصيح
الحكومه حول القانون الدولي بذلك القانون
الدولي الانساني وهذا لم يتغير منذ السابع
من اكتوبر ان الصراع مع
حماسي يشكل تحديات قانونيه وعسكريه في
عمليات مدنيه مع تقليل الضرر
على المدنيين مع استخدام حماس
للمستشفيات في مساعده المدنيين في مغادره
المناطق ذات الكثافه الناريه في حين حماس
تجبرهم على الوقوف امام خط نار وفي تسهيل
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه بهذه المساعدات
التي تسرقها حماس من اجل استريه عمليات
العسكريه ان الاعتبارات
الانسانيه ضد خصومنا الذين لا يزالون
يطلقون الصواريخ داخل بلادنا ويحتجزون
مواطنين
اسرى كجه المسؤول عن تقديم المشوره عن
القانون الدولي للحكومه الاسرائيليه
يمكنني ان اشهدوا بانه مع هذه التحديات
اسرائيل لا تزال ملتزمه بالقانون الدولي
عندما دوت المدافع في غزه القانون لم
يصمت هذه كانت هي الحاله منذ انشات
اسرائيل في عام 1948 عندما تم تبني
اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعي اسرائيل
بالتزامها بالقانون الدولي لا تزال ثابته
وراسه عبر التاريخ بالرغم من التحديات
التي نواجهها
كامه وهي تعكس التزام الذي قدمته الدوله
عندما تم انشاؤها والذي ايضا يتجسد في
اعلان الاعلان وفيه مرجعيه مباشره الى
ميثاق الامم المتحده في عام
1948 ايضا اسرائيل ايضا اجبر
عليها وبالرغم من انها كانت في حرب
وجود الا ان الدوله الان اعطت اهميه كبيره
لانشاء منظومه قانونيه مستقله ومحاي على
الفور و اول
خطوات قام بها الجيش في وسط الحرب هو
انشاء منظومه محكمه
عسكريه وهذه المحكمه اصبحت جزءا لا يتجزا
من
الهيكل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهنالك المسؤول عن هذه الوحده
هو من اعلى المراتب العسكريه وهي مستقله
عن تسلسل القياده العسكري وطاقمها بما في
ذلك خبراء في القانون
الدولي هم من جزء من جميع الانشطه
العسكريه المختلفه وهم يقدمون التدريب
القانوني والتثقيف وهم يساعدون في صياغه
والاعداد للخطط والعقائد العسكريه
والعقيده العسكريه هم يقدمون المشوره
العسكريه المستمره على النطاق من المواضيع
بما في ذلك الاستهداف والاستخدام الاسلحه
والواجبات تجاه العدو
والمجتمع المدني هذا يبقى هو وهذه هي
الحال سائده في الحرب الحاليه ان المنظومه
القضائيه الاسرائيل بم بذلك دائرتي في
وزاره العدل تخدمه كمنص لمراجعه للمنظومه
العسكريه ان الامين العام هو يراس
المنظومه القضائيه المدنيه وفي هذا المنصب
هي ايضا تتمتع بالاستقلاليه الدستوريه
الكامله وفي كل الاوقات
الابواب للمحاكم الاسرائيليه بما في ذلك
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه
مشرعه هذه
المحكمه معروفه
بنظري كل ما يتعلق بمارسه الاعمال
العدائيه بما في ذلك اعمال العدائيه
المستمره وفي الواقع اثناء الصراع القائم
المحكمه قامت بالنظر في التماسات لجوانب
مرتبطه بهذه الحرب اسرائيل بمنظومتها
القانونيه تضمن ايضا المساءله ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لديه
منظومه قويه جدا ايضا اليات مستقله
للتحقيق في ايه انتهاكات للقانون الدولي
الانساني هذه الاليه خاضعه للمراقبه
والاشراف من قبل المنظومه المدنيه
القانونيه بما في ذلك المحكمه العليا
فالنظام تم تعزيزه ايضا على على مدى
العقود الماضيه بما في ذلك بالتشاور مع
الدول ذات نفس الذهنيه والخبراء الدوليين
ان
المساعد في الحوادث الاعمال العدائيه
الكبيره خارج حدوث الوله تحتاج الخبراء
منظومتنا تقدم موارد كافيه وسلطات للوفاء
بواجباتها ان الاليات العسكريه هي ايضا
تراجعوا حوادث لها علاقه بالصراع الجاري
ان حكم القانون يبقى اساسا وعمو في دوله
اسرائيل ومقدم
الدعوه هو يتحدى ليس فقط القياده
الاسرائيليه وانما المجتمع الاسرائيلي
سيدي الرئيس ان الاشاره الى نيه وجود اباد
جماعيه
و ان مجلس المستشار الاسرائيلي البروفيسور
شو تحدث عن
هذا القلق والالم العميق الذي اختبره
المجتمع الا اسرائيل منذ السابع من
اكتوبر كان فيه بعض البيانات الصعبه او
قويه ضد العدو وكان طبعا مردا على ما يقال
من تدمير ليه الدوله الاسرائيليه لكن نظ
نظامنا يعرف كي يفصل الفرق ما بين
الخطابات التي قد تكون
مغلقه وحق التعبير في وحق التعبير في دوله
ديمقراطيه وفي تلك البيانات التي تجاوز
هذه الحقوق وكمين العام اكدت علنا بان اي
بيان يدعو الى ضرر متعمد للمدنيين يتعارض
مع سياسه دوله اسرائيل وقد يرتقي الى تهمه
جنائيه بما في ذلك جريمه
التحريض عدد من هذه الحالات الان يتم
النظر فيها من قبل ال جهات انفاذ القانوني
الاسرائيليه وستجد الافادات في التبويب 17
دا في الملف سيدتي الرئيس الرئيس اعضاء
المحكمه
كما
هنالك تداعيات على مثل من هذه من
هذه الطلبات على اسرائيل وعلى المجتمع
الدولي لاننا بصدد صراع عسكري له تداعيات
على كلا طرفي الصراع تداعيات كبيره نعم
هنالك
صراع عسكري ولكن محاوله تصنيفه كابا
جماعيه وطلب هذه التدابير الوقائيه هو ليس
غير الاساس له حتى في القانون وانما له
تداعيات سلبيه ممتده حتى على ابعد من
القضيه المنظوره امامكم في نهايه المطاف
ان البحث في نظري مقدم الدعوه هو لا يعزز
فقط من الاباده الجماعيه والاتفاقيه وانما
يضعفها
ستصبح هي اداه تبنها المجتمع الدولي لمنع
روعات ما حوادث هزت ضمير العرب العالم مثل
الهولوكوست
وستصبح ووضعها كسلاح بين يدي المجموعات
الارهابيه التي لا اعتبار لها للانسانيه
وللقانون الدولي
واذا لجا اي دوله لدفاع عن نفسها ضد اي
تنظيم ارهابي سيصبح هذا اباده جماعيه
واستخدام التدابير
المؤقته ان الدول لدها الحق في الدفاع عن
نفسها ضد المنظمات
الارهابيه
وهذا ايضا اذا تم الموافقه عليه ستكون
اشاره للمجموعات الارهابيه انها تستطيع
ارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم حرب
واستغلال هذا من اجل الحصول على الحمايه
من المحكمه بالنسبه لنا التدابير المؤقته
سوف تؤدي الى وضع معكوس او عكسي سوف تتيح
لحماس على الفور من الاستمرار بمهاجمه
مواطني اسرائيل
ول الابقاء على 106 اسرى في ظروف صعبه جدا
والابقاء عشرات الالاف من النازحين
الاسرائيليين من العوده منع العوده
منازلهم و للمتابعه ب سعيها وذبح اكبر عدد
ممكن من الاسرائيل واليهود سيدتي الرئيس
اعضاء المحكمه في
ذكرى
احداث ال تاسيس دوله
اسرائيل نحن نبر
جهودا لتحويل معنى الاباده الجماعيه
اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه هي جزء من طموح البشريه لتصدي
للوحش
وشرور
و ومع هذه الثقه بالقانون الدولي
ومؤسساتها من اجل يجب ان تبدد
هذه المساع نطلب من المحكمه ان لا تذهب في
هذا الطريق الخطير سيدتي الرئيسه اعضاء
المحكمه
لكل الاسباب التي ذكرتها انفا اسرائيل
تطلب من المحكمه بموجب القرار 16 الفقره
اثنين من قوا النظام الاساسي وللاسباب
المقدمه اثناء المرافعه في
يناير الثاني عش من يناير ان تجد المحكمه
اولا او ان ترفض الطلب بفرض التدابير
المؤقته المقدم من قبل جهه مقدمه الدعوه
ثانيا رفع القضيه عن قائمتها سيدتي
الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه بهذا اختتم مرافعه
اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لكم على حسن اصغاء
شكرا